[Music]
stretching way back to my childhood I
wanted to understand time being shown
the stars through a telescope and told
that you know what I was seeing was
thousands of years in the past to me it
was a mystery that the absent flows of
time
[Music]
my name is gem finer and I've composed
long-player which is a an everlasting
piece of music that repeats every
thousand years long player started
playing at the beginning of the year
2000 around the middle of the 1990s the
millennium started to be discussed a lot
but really all that was being discussed
were very short ways of celebrating it a
few nights of fireworks and parties it
seemed to me there's a kind of absurdity
about celebrating something so long by
strategies that were so short so one of
the things that interested me as making
this thousand years tangible it occurred
to me one day that the best way I could
do that was to write a piece of music
if you imagine taking six copies of the
same record and playing them on six
different turntables do you spin each
turntable at a different speed you're
moving through the material at different
points on each one and in that way you
get a relationship that never resolves
never comes back into phase until
exactly after a thousand years so what
these singing bowls are here are all the
bowls that are necessary to play any
point of long-player in its
thousand-year long duration you think
the singing bowl was just this ballad
you just hit it and it sounds but
actually they're very complex it's like
there's all sorts of sounds in that that
you can tease out in different ways the
future of long player could go many
different ways you don't know what's
going to happen
technologically politically culturally
ecologically it creates this continuum
of people a community of listeners and
caretakers across generations until the
31st of December 2000 999 at which point
it will get back to where first started
and start again
[Music]
they sound a lot like voices or like an
angry choir somebody told me that they
sound a lot like sniffing a whole lot of
magic markers all at once you can decide
for yourself
I'm Andy Kappa torta and I'm a sculptor
I work with robotics and with sound
the work that I mostly do involves
creating new types of music of
instruments or new types of physical
sounds a lot of times this has a lot to
do with motion and form what I'm sitting
next to right here it's called the
dervishes it's got these fourteen
spinning arms it's similar to the toys
that you played with as a kid where you
might spin a corrugated plastic tube
over your head
there's a lot of circuit boards in here
for motor control and we measure the
speeds very precisely and then there's a
lot of software that takes the specific
pitches figures out exactly where they
should be played and at what speeds it's
a lot of fine tuning all the way through
from the music that gets written for it
to the software but calibrates and
adjusts and controls it all the way
through to the fine tuning and the motor
controllers what I do is a bit on a
parallel track with a lot of what's
happening in electronic music but I work
specifically almost exclusively with
physical sound almost never with
synthesized sound or samples or stuff
like that just because those are the
ones that actually have the most meaning
to me
all my life I've been interested in
sound I think it's how I figure things
out I always love when these instruments
creates the possibility to make music
that didn't exist before
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Alex Holman and I play tenor
smith-corona with the Boston typewriter
Orchestra the Boston typer - orchestra
is an ensemble for typewriter invoice
some of us have musical backgrounds some
of us don't several of our members play
in bands currently I haven't touched
much of anything except for typewriters
since playing the trombone in high
school we play a wide variety of
typewriters from some small portable
models all the way up to some relatively
large desk models a lot of what we do in
building up songs is really exploring
what different sounds we can get out of
the typewriter and how we can
incorporate them into a song for example
you have the the key makes it of a a
basic clack sound but then you have the
the shift that moves a lot of mechanics
and make somewhat of a bass sound then
you also have the the roller that gets a
get sort of a mechanical ratchet sound
to it and then only when we can work
with the carriage return for like that
you know the standard sweep you sound to
it as our name suggests the Boston
typewriter Orchestra is Boston based but
we've actually played all over New
England
most of the typewriters are 50 60 70
years old usually in our hands we see
two to three years of lifespan we feed
on them pretty hard when we started out
in 2004 we were we were a bunch of guys
getting together and kind of banging on
typewriters we get that we're kind of
weird it's a little bit of a wacky idea
but we've discovered that this makes
some legitimate music and you know it
can be a real serious endeavor we have
true songs that come together and people
seem to really enjoy them and as long as
we still are entertaining people we're
gonna stay out there typing
[Music]
very often people think it's gonna be
funny and then they realize it's not
really
we really do music it's not impossible
to make music with vegetables my name is
Susanna got Maya and then I'm a member
of the vegetable orchestra the orchestra
exists since 18 years now if there's
instrument Boston tomato because you can
do sound with tomatoes but it will be
messy for sure we go shopping on the
market first we choose all the
vegetables there we have three kinds of
instruments one is the ready mate you
can just buy it at the market and play
it it's like the pepper it's called snow
it's ready already and then there are
the simple instruments like with one cut
or some cuts to get it like that then
with the more complex instruments we
have some that work like normal
instruments you know the pumpkin is the
bass drum and the sound of the pumpkin
is really important after shopping we go
to the venue and start to build
instruments all in all it takes 2 to 3
hours to paint all the instruments for
everybody and then we start with the
soundcheck
and since we have new instruments each
time we have to have a very long
soundcheck
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a lot of different musical
influences in the orchestra since
they're really many people everybody's
interested in different things we make
soup during the building process of the
vegetable instruments with the remaining
vegetables when we serve it to the
audience after the concert and it's also
after hearing and seeing us and smelling
the vegetables which will be intense in
there because it's so small this theater
and then you can also eat it you never
get it out of your head anymore if
you're in the orchestra to look
vegetables in another way
[Applause]
[Music]
there's the rulers the reverb tank the
e-book
[Music]
a normal instrument you're playing it
and you're expecting it to have a sound
that is pleasing but with an instrument
like this the goal is to just produce
sounds that's in this case so disturbing
[Music]
the apprehension engine was an
instrument that creates a variety of
really creepy and someone say horrifying
sounds
my name is Marc Corvin I'm a film music
composer and lately I've been focusing
on horror movie scores two of my biggest
hits as far as horror films are
concerned was from the late 90s a film
called cube and most recently the which
I originally commissioned the
apprehension Asian because I was tired
and the same digital samples which which
resulted in a lot of sameness of a lot
of horror musics so I was looking for
something more experimental more
acoustic that would give me a little bit
more of an original sound that's where I
contacted my friend Tony Duggan Smith so
Marc called me asking me to create a
crazy instrument for horror films
because I've never done anything like
that before
it may be empty out my pockets and all
my drawers of any knickknacks and bits
and bobs I could possibly spend together
to make it happen for him and this is
what camera
[Music]
you're doing those things that stir
crammed emotions and feelings and there
actually is a skill set that you have to
acquire in order to to get the most out
of it
it expresses what really can't be
expressed any other way it's not music
in the traditional sense at all but let
me put it this way the apprehension
engine definitely evokes an emotion so I
would call it easy
you
[Music]